le canada est maintenant lui aussi dans
la course au vaccin contre le
coronavirus avec une trentaine d'autres
équipes d'un monde
l'objectif irbid ces 18 mois peut être
moins mais com sef réussi à réaliser un
vaccin sécurité en aussi peu de temps et
pour une aussi grande population
ce serait du jamais vu développements et
tests sur l'animal premier test chez
l'humain étude de grande envergure et
approbation au total on parle
habituellement d'une quinzaine d'années
pour mettre vaccin marché comment
va-t-on obtenir le même résultat en dix
fois moins de temps essentiellement
diminuant la durée de chacune des étapes
de sa fabrication de la conception aux
essais à grande échelle par exemple les
les études précliniques dans les animaux
ils se font en même temps qu'on prépare
les secret nec pour que dès qu'on
termine on a juste besoin de mettre les
volontaires de plus au lieu de tester le
produit sur un grand nombre de gens de
tous les groupes d'âge
on va cibler plus précisément les
candidats est ce qu'on doit se rendre à
cent mille personnes avant de vraiment
déterminé le vaccin est efficace jusqu'à
quel point
ou est-ce qu'on peut le faire l'on peut
voir beaucoup et bien avant donc
personne ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'on prend des raccourcis avec des
thérapies expérimentales
le vaccin contre les mollahs dont nortel
t de 70% a été testé en un temps record
il pour traiter le vih
un grand nombre de patients très malades
ou servi de cobaye à la science dans le
contexte vih sida y avait rien d'autre à
faire dont on a changé une carte de
référence aux dix ans à cause du
contexte de risques incroyables où il
n'y a aucun entraînement c'est justifier
des interventions
est ce que cette fois ci encore la fin
justifie les moyens
probablement mais pas n'importe quel
prix de précaution c'est avec une
obligation on continue une fois qu'on
aura développé
où les futurs vaccins il faudrait aussi
s'assurer qu'ils sont accessibles à tous
c'est vraiment le mot magique ici qu'il
faut garder en tête pour que les gens
puissent avoir accès au vaccin pour ceux
qui le demandent
ici normand grondin à radio canada
montréal